mes héros moi c'est vous mais les airs
et numéros ce sont ceux que j'ai côtoyés
depuis trois ans je pensais que je me
souviendrai de vous tous à cette
assemblée au delà de nos espérances
ce fut une extraordinaire période de ma
vie de vous côtoyez c'était un honneur
et un privilège que de représenter louis
la circonscription de gatineau mais
surtout tu siéger dans cette assemblée
nationale pour être réellement efficace
il faut être bien appuyé bien entouré et
surtout être constamment à les coupes du
monde qui nous a désignés pour rire
présenté d'excusés et sentir la
confiance de notre résultat grâce la sas
monica pour affirmer primitive et
restèrent expérientiel huacas la sotra
ce match
gracias porto merci à tous aussi arrivé
de tous côtés
une nouvelle cohorte de députés qui
veulent rétablir la confiance en notre
système via notre démocratie
je leur lève mon chapeau et je leur
tends le flambeau je ne peux pas passer
sous silence de départ de mon collègue
amir khadir meilleur j'aimerais vraiment
te remercier pour tout refaire
jamais tu as beaucoup donné au québec
aux québécois et aux québécoises de
l'admiration et de l'amitié pour toi et
je t'emmerde
ils sont bien mis au total
[Applaudissements]